car là est la seule femme de la planète
à posséder les clés du septième ciel
un premier ascenseur puis un deuxième où
il faut jouer les sardines en boîte le
temps d'une drôle de progression et
soudain c'est le paradis une chambre au
milieu des nuages un morceau d'horizon
pour tous vis-à-vis
en
et plus haut encore sur l'infini un
balcon qui tourne sur lui-même à 360
degrés
ce promontoire extraordinaire c'est en
fait une ancienne grue de chantier naval
transformé par cette audacieuse et son
mari en tour eiffel de la côte
hollandaise le défi c'était d'allier le
charme de l'ancien outil portuaire et le
confort du 21e siècle pari tenu
cela vous réglez la lumière les
toilettes de la douche vous pouvez
prendre une douche en bleu rouge vert
bleu jaune blanc aile droite sur le quai
d'en face
voilà l'autre folie de carla un phare du
19e siècle auquel on accède au bout de
80 marche et où l'on dort aussi
perché sur le toit du monde
pour la plupart des gens dormir dans un
endroit original est un rêve
ils ne veulent plus aller dans les
hôtels qu'elles sont coulés chambres
sont toutes les mêmes surtout pour fêter
une occasion spéciale comme le gardien
d'autrefois le locataire d'un soir peut
choisir le morceau de cartes postales
qu'il contemplera avant de se coucher le
luxe grandeur nature